michael bay drives towards the energy of
a scene
you are all gonna have the greatest joy
to tell at the end of the night he's
trying to move with what feels alive
bring it low and start to go up michael
was getting different shots that he
would usually never shoot so it gave it
a very different style
i've done nine movies with michael and
one of my first jobs on every movie is
what's the newest coolest gear out there
so on this movie it's called fpv three
two
one an action michael gives us very
concise direction you understand what
i'm saying because you're watching on a
tight lens here and you hold two more
seconds on a movie screen and it needs
it
yeah but he gives us the ability to be
creative my name is alex vanover and i'm
a drone pilot on this movie ambulance
michael bay best pilot we know over here
when i'm flying the drone i'm acting
like superman in a way where i'm trying
to get these really unique angles and
shots
i fly what's called an fpv drone and fpv
stands for first person view so we wear
a set of goggles on our face and when
i'm flying the drone i'm actually flying
with a vr headset and i'm able to see
exactly what the drone sees in real time
so it's a whole new arena for flying and
allows us to fly in really crazy
locations
and get some really awesome shots you
can't really get with any other camera
or drum oh look at that oh white
go go go go go you have to watch it on
the big screen the way that it was shot
that experience is just magical lock
everything down
nothing gets out it belongs in the
theater and i cannot wait for it to be
in a theater
this is definitely one where people will
enjoy going on that ride for two hours
hopefully they leave the theater
sweating we don't get to walk off into
the sunset
[Music]